la vague de froid n'est pas encore
terminée mais les dégâts sur la vigne et
les arbres sont déjà considérables en
indre et loire après avoir allumé des
bougies ou implorer le ciel les
agriculteurs vont recevoir l'aide de
l'état confirmation tout à l'heure du
ministre de l'agriculture julien de
normandie en visite dans le vouvrillon
hélène chapelet avec audrey champigny
comme partout en france à cette parcelle
de 4 mille mètres carré de vigne n'a pas
été épargné par le gel des derniers
jours implanté sur les hauteurs de
rochecorbon et ses pieds vieux d'une
soixantaine d'années en ont pourtant vu
d'autres
pour alain qui exploite ses terres il
est encore trop tôt pour réellement
estimé la hauteur des pertes certains
bourgeon n'était pas encore sorti et
d'autres pourraient survivre
seymour se sait menacé moeurs ceci cela
normalement il est sauvé tiré d'affaires
on observe même une grappe sua est mort
dans notre misère le fait que ces gelées
de bonheur tous les yeux étaient pas
démarré ça veut dire qu'ils aillent en
année des petites de secours on s'est
peut-être qu'ils peuvent de ning rap on
en sera certainement plus à fin avril ne
sera l'heure des comptes mais là
aujourd'hui les comptes sont quand même
globalement côté rim clan ce constat le
ministre de l'agriculture est venu le
faire sur le terrain julien de normandie
s'est rendu ce vendredi après midi sur
une parcelle de vigne à parçay-meslay
pour assurer les vignerons du soutien de
l'état
par contre impossible pour l'instant de
connaître le montant de l'enveloppé qui
sera débloquée le dispositif de soutien
devra être à l'autre à la hauteur d'un
phénomène climatique tout à fait
exceptionnelle avec des très fortes
chaleurs puis une chute brutale des
températures et donc avec des dégâts que
je qualifierais de très important à
l'échelle de l'ensemble de la maison
france agricole sert plus de dix régions
sur 13 sont impactés difficile de faire
un bilan des pertes sur les deux mille
deux cent cinquante hectares de
l'appellation vouvray et les huit
communes concernées ont toutes été
touchées différemment et les prochains
jours avec l'annoncé d'une nouvelle
période de jeu
elles seront déterminants